president biden travels to belgium this
week for a high-stakes meeting with
american allies he will also go to
poland which has taken care of more than
2 million refugees from ukraine but the
president has no plans to visit ukraine
itself ed o'keefe has a preview of the
trip
as russia's invasion of ukraine is in
its fourth week president biden is set
to meet with the leaders of other nato
countries in the coming days
on the agenda possible additional
sanctions against russia more
humanitarian assistance for refugees and
military aid for nato troops near the
ukrainian border you've seen
deliberate targeting of cities and towns
and civilians defense secretary lloyd
austin told face the nation sunday the
current tactics are a possible sign
russian president vladimir putin's
military campaign is losing momentum his
campaign is stalled he's not been able
to achieve the goals as rapidly that he
wants to achieve as rapidly as he wants
to achieve them
and he warned against any further
escalation by russia if a chemical or
biological weapon was used you'd see a
significant reaction from not only the
united states but also the global
community on that point there's
bipartisan agreement the use of chemical
weapons is certainly something that
would alter our calculation with growing
speculation about ongoing talks between
ukraine and russia the ukrainian
ambassador to the u.s said she still
hopes for a diplomatic solution
negotiate does not mean to surrender
we are not ready to give up on either
our
dreams on the territorial sovereignty or
integrity but we are ready to negotiate
even with the brutal enemy in order to
stop it
later this morning the president will
speak with the leaders of france germany
italy and great britain
about their ongoing coordinated response
that trip to poland later this week is
designed to thank that country for
absorbing so many ukrainian refugees
tony a big week of diplomacy ahead for
the president
everybody hoping for a breakthrough in
those talks ed thank you very much